the playoffs and she's with christian
thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with stavrou last arula first of all how
do you feel after these two very intense
games yesterday you were lost then you
were completely winning then it ended up
in a draw today it felt like she was
putting some pressure on you how did you
feel about this matchup
yeah both games were pretty intense and
today i guess i was
quite lucky to survive because like i
was under pressure
and yeah i'm glad that we're going to
the playoffs honestly
so you have a positive feeling about the
going into the playoffs
i mean
anything could happen but i guess
i feel like i could have some chance
you have a few minutes you have a few
minutes right now to get ready are you
going to go get some fresh air are you
going to go check your laptop to see
some new ideas what are you going to do
well we don't have that much time for to
check a lot but i guess i'll just rest
for a bit just decide what to play and
yeah
staff ruler thank you very much for uh
joining us guys any questions
no just good luck and these playoffs i
know they're
nerve wracking so uh
my best advice to you is just to keep a
calm mind and uh don't get too
uh
how do you say uh focus that you don't
play easily in these playoffs it's gonna
be a very fast time control so good luck
thank you so much cheers
all right we'll have those playoffs
coming up very very